[Music]
if you've got a problem with zack snyder
offering up his near mythical curt of
2017's justice league
well superman has a problem with you
speaking with the happy sad confused
podcast
henry cavill who has portrayed big blue
in the films of the dc extended universe
offered up a concise and thorough
justification for why snyder's cut of
the film should be seen
cavall also had strong praise for
schneider as a filmmaker
and an interesting analysis of the
director's perceived shortcomings
in case you're somehow unaware of the
rocky road justice league took to the
screen
some background snyder who previously
directed 2013's man of steel
and 2016 batman vs superman dawn of
justice
was forced to depart justice league
midway through production
due to a family tragedy stepping in to
finish the film was avengers director
joss whedon
who most observers agreed was pretty
qualified at least on paper
unfortunately whedon apparently under
mandate from warner brothers simply took
a baseball bat to snyder's film
rewriting around 80 pages of its script
and tossing huge chunks of narrative out
the window
entire character arcs like that of ray
fisher cyborg whom snyder had called the
heart of his movie via twitter
evaporated other characters like
darkseid disappeared altogether
the finished product barely resembled
the film snyder envisioned i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us united
justice league became perhaps the
highest grossing flop in history
despite being the first live-action
appearance of one of the most legendary
superhero teams in history
following a brief round of reshoots and
a complete re-edit by snyder using
precisely none of whedon's footage
hbo max will present snyder's version of
the film as a four-part mini-series
sometime in 2021
and cavil for one couldn't be happier
about it cavill began his defense on the
snyder curt by strongly insinuating that
whedon
who has since come under fire for
allegedly running a hostile borderline
abusive shoot via variety
was simply never the right guy for the
job being less invested in the
characters than snyder
cavill said when it comes to adaptations
and stuff it's important to me that
things are
faithful to the source material when you
adjust a carriage on someone else's
train
it can be a dangerous place to be in
when you are the train itself
when you are the lord of the rings
director peter jackson when you are
zack snyder when you are june director
danny vilnev it is i'm sure
absolutely amazing because it's your
vision the key word here is vision
few would argue against snider's talent
as a visual stylist or even that he's
capable of pulling off virtuoso
sequences
for evidence look no further than his
feature debut the 2004 remake of dawn of
the dead
which spawns one of the most terrifying
opening scenes in horror movie history
but the filmmaker has endured criticism
for jumbled plotting and hokey dialogue
particularly with regard to batman vs
superman dawn of justice
and cavill feels that such criticism
tends to overlook the forest for the
trees the actor makes the case that
snyder is actually an underrated
storyteller
one that simply employs a different set
of tools than most
caval dished zack's attention to detail
zach's visual talent is extraordinary
and the way he tells stories you see it
through the visual he's such an
exceptional crafter of moments
and love him or hates him everyone talks
about the movies that he makes
i've learned a lot from his version of
storytelling in the sense that he relies
on those moments very
very much he's very much in the visual
medium and he's so good at it
zack's visuals are second to none and
it's something which i'm going to take
with me
by all accounts snyder's cut of justice
league is sure to be radically different
from the version we saw in 2017 so we'll
get to see just what cavill's talking
about when snyder's curt hits hbo max
next year for now we'll be on the
lookout for an official release date
announcement and we'll keep you informed
and as always we'll be keeping the faith
thank you
for what for believing in me
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you